This is the kind of thing that makes people lose trust
in the medical community
and in the journalism community.
As a female who has breastfed two babies,
I can tell you that there is a
massive list of DOS and don'ts for breastfeeding.
Every single doctor,
every single nurse,
every single medical expert I have ever heard from
emphasize how important it is
to watch what you are eating,
watch what medicine you are taking,
even the creams you're putting on your face.
Because all of those things
can get into the breast milk,
even if it's just little traces.
You want the breast milk to be as pure
as possible for your baby.
That is why we breastfeed,
is to give them what they need.
Mothers everywhere know this.
They're very, very,
very careful about what they put into their bodies
when they are breastfeeding a baby.
And the reason that we are so careful
is because we prioritize the health
and the well being of our babies
above our own wants and desires
for different substances and medicine and food.
This is the exact opposite of that.
This is narcissism on a level I have never seen before.
Children are not props.
Children are not lifestyle accessories.
Children are
the most important people in this entire world,
and they deserve better than this.